at what point did you start getting
scripts and it to you was there a point
where you could tell you were in demand
it wasn't just your ego like you you saw
like this is this is turned a corner
sure I mean a lot of it is people you
know I'm known for being other people's
videos because I have a you know I have
a lot of experience in comedy which a
lot of youtubers they they don't they
start at YouTube and then they're like
oh well you know i'd like to do comedy
and I've done kind of like the hard work
though the tens of thousands of hours of
auditions comedy writing and I think
people found like well this guy is in
Sony pools others videos like I guess he
needs to be in mind he has a big skill
set so I found that people started
contacting me and I'm a yes man you know
you come here you're just like yes yes
yes and then you realize you can't say
yes to everything because it dilute your
work in time and it just it just it's
just not possible so you know I didn't
notice that um especially in YouTube or
writing and lately I say no a lot not
because it's not good and not because I
don't want to but there's just really
not the time and I just know I don't
have I know I could can't give it a
hundred percent there's so many great
people around I'd rather you have
somebody that can give you give you that
give you that hundred percent so yeah
it's great but I never sit there and
wait ever ever I get up and I follow up
and and I think if you I like to a bit
of advice that won't drive you crazy i
was at a point where if I don't have a
good improv show all right end of a
commercial audition my happiness and
kind of validation depended on that and
I started kind of losing my mind a
little bit and then I kind of was like
you know what I don't care about any of
it and I went back to school and was
taking anthropology classes just to use
my brain a different way as soon as I
did that everything started having the
YouTube stuff kind of exploded for me
it's because I kind of didn't put I
didn't put my value into light one thing
so i was like i can write i can produce
i can act i could create I can you know
make you tea i'm not a really good
shooter an editor like a data kind of
leave to people that are more competent
but i wanted to make sure i had a bunch
of skills put a bunch of things out
there even the traditional space i have
two screenplays i have a
pilot TV pilot out there so I have a lot
of things out there this way if like one
thing isn't working out for other things
are or two things are working out three
aren't great I haven't kind of put all
my eggs in one basket and this probably
sounds easier said than done especially
you're trying to achieve something from
Ground Zero but would you recommend that
other people find quick at Hobby whether
it's knitting or Deepak Chopra books or
something that's outside the industry so
that they're not so focused on my looks
my validation my social media numbers
yeah I mean what I learned what I
started doing improv comedy is to have a
have a real life outside of comedy
because what's funny it what's funny
comedy things that are funny are not
funny it's the real life that's funny
when a stand up and talks about his
family he's he that's what's funny about
his family's not today they're talking
about comedy or I was hanging out with
other means sometimes they do but I
think having having a real life and real
relationships and kind of having
interest in other things you could take
I mean you might you know if you're you
said knitting I mean if you're on
somebody who can like knit and do
something else that might be your
youtube video and and that might be
interesting with someone because you're
kind of crossing over like well I love
knitting I can relate to this person I
love things that are funny you come one
and stay for the other yet for me I mean
I always have a story to tell and and I
kind of if you're out there and you have
you hear things I'm like that's funny or
like that den interaction is funny
what's funny about it how can I make a
video out of it so yes absolutely
you